wenn ich jetzt so spritzig hat mit dem
ihf und ehf reagierte gereizt auf
die live show von coburg sie und immer
mit dem thema vertraut was ich mache das
nicht aggressiv und wie wahrscheinlich
wieder das klinikum aktiviert und denke
nicht an geduldig sie so und
sagenfiguren
unterstützt
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum laichen bossard
und dem oha in bassen live mit einer
großartigen publikum
der aktuelle stand der felizitas anlagen
und äußerst du bist sie ihre therapeutin
paartherapeutin sich einig für den
bekanntesten dieser schweiz mit der
funktion vor allem sieht ute podcast
beziehungs cosmos s zahl mit der sabine
meyer und die alle kennen sich mit dem
problem zu der erste frage die ich
gerade alle reden darüber johnny depp
und
was würde denn
das ist wirklich dass ich in der nutzer
unterschätzt für komplexe hatte ich sie
noch eine rettung wenn sie wach zu
werden
ich weiß auch nicht wieso
ich bin sehr schmal und will will dabei
die sehr
es levantes konstruktion ist sehr schwer
fassbar und wenn du wenn du wieso nicht
spielt weil sie verhindert also findet
bei die sind ja auch im schauspiel zu
schwierig winterspiele was ist denn was
bunt aber ruppert ruf und was ich dann
unter wirklich
verfahren weltweit möglichst
sympathischer unglaublich viel bar und
man fragt sich natürlich so als zero
therapeutin starker sagt problem
ja zum glück im fall zum glück kann ja
selber problem ich finde meine eigene
themen immer mitunter bis vor
spannungsspitzen besser verstehen wie
man funktioniert und finden das ist auch
wichtig zu sagen ich habe selten so viel
klärt wir verdienen und klienten will
ich reflektiere denn mit einer ihre
themen und dank so oft am ende der
stunde aber die konter besser
integriert sie hier also ist tatsächlich
verständlich dass zum beispiel
kommunikation ist das thema wo immer
grundsätzlich ist das thema wo immer und
perspektivenwechsel wo starb ist
gegenüber und wenn wir zum beispiel
situation analysieren ausführlich und
zeit hätten sie mit vorn
und ich meine
gedanken gewissens bist du nicht
vielleicht die perspektive partner mit
ibc und gerade so ich habe das gefühl
ich bin nur wertschätzen und
sorgfältiger mit ihm wenn ich diesen
sieg
übrigens mit dem podcast aufnahme
von eck kommunikation ist es wichtig
weiter wird sagt und wie genau er will
die kommunikation ist wirklich seine
hauptfigur zimmer gefragt wurde das
thema wo jedes paar rund um das würzige
ohne
kommunikationsstelle gibt es passend
dass es das ist was nach und wird und
nach das ist das nicht so spannend
findet er immer sei es zurück zum col de
was sind für motiv darunter das sind die
fragen und das sind vielleicht sogar für
unbewusste glaubenssatz und emotionen
beteiligt aber dass man dass mussawi die
kommunikation aber interessante schau
ebenso in trolleys mit der unterstadt
ist klar das thema linie hätte eine
extrem wichtig ist man muss miteinander
reden und dann mussten wir lehren und
ich kann mich noch erinnern
paartherapeut der juwi gehört er später
wieder verstorben und sag mir mal so
imponiert wie derzeit höher manfred das
ist so ein er war immer so viel redet
macht problem herr bieri macht bis
mitternacht zum beispiel ganze hatte ja
ja ja das gute metapher bhs dort seien
ja da war ja alles okay das aussortieren
wir vielleicht dank weg wird nicht im
garten wobei mir dann zurückgemietet
worden ist das gute oder schlechte ruf
zurück geben wird und dass sich ja gar
nicht so schlecht zu suchen
möglich also ebene grund soll sachen als
dank an luca inklusive sie mit dem tod
ich finde es wirklich das wichtigste
mein fahrrad gäste respond to aufgaben
schlusskurs über nach sagte ken ist sie
ist ihr verhindert durch hätte dass er
wirklich seine spieler stellt und was
eigentlich wenn windows retten kann ja
machen erstens kann ich machen dass sie
wieder weg informiert und das retten
haben auch dass der fokus kann überlegt
und wie denn die muss gehört werden und
darum wenn du mir das wird
unbedingt also es geht es komplett zu
viel an reden aber er in das oft brachte
birgit so mega mega bronze
gab es gibt
kinder muss das ist ja also das ist ein
begriff wie normal projekte
pforzheimer geschafft hat und zwar dass
man habe so rieben schafft wo man
versuch aus dieser kreditlinie ried vor
der zeit zu unterbrechen was mir da
handys wir sind ständig von einer ist
nächste und irgendwie also die ruhe
finde oder also klebt das aber bis ich
sie und wieder zum gegenüber gott dass
mir das ganz bewusst plant und das heißt
er wird einfach so blanc kritik an dem
plan das macht mir wirklich stand der
dinge omega zeit aber es gibt im fall
sogar omega zeit die wir selber und eine
gewisse das den garten spazieren und
ganz viel selbst gesprengt
denn mach das einfach mit mir an
staplern partner und sowie versuche
erblasser oft spannende wo man sich lieb
versinkt derzeit und dieses thema oft
nicht so erfüllt wie die tatsächliche
zeit vergangen ist also im besten fall
führt eine sehr wohl gar nicht und ein
hatte dass er besucht haben also gezielt
paar zeit so wie es nicht zeigt mietern
jetzt ein paar zu unterstreichen agenda
gehen wir mit seiner wetterbericht haben
klasse bitte hier beschrieben worden
einige lacher ja nicht ganz mächtig also
ihr redet gern vor die steine im fluss
alltag ist so getaktet und gemeinde
schaut das partizip ganz auf die musik
die ist es zwar wichtig und ich sage ich
wette aus wie auch immer
aber de facto kein team ran da ist
zuerst und es wird unterschätzt wie
wichtig das ist der report sieht einfach
der roomster ungestört die was nicht mag
es
wurden sogar
ohne das wissen was man gemacht aber
ich meine das ist eigentlich ein tipp so
die faz muss wahrscheinlich schon länger
gibt
schönes leben natürlich dafür merke
immer gern aber ich erinnere mich zum
spiel hat die schwedische serie borgen
morgen geht ist sie wirklich so die
machen genauso sextäter ich sehe so aus
sextapes genau machen das machen
der marsch ganz begeistert mit den
prominenten wird ja dass wir den podcast
klose wisse dass omega 6 machen von mir
ist es aber ich sitze finden noch ein
stress verband aber durch meinen als
romantisch ist dass die stadt wie
sozusagen die krippe die romantik mit
dem fall strauss zum und nur geht
einfach dass der knoten
platzt das muss man dann eben auftakt am
liebsten in alltag allein oder zu zweit
will das natürlich ein luxus sie also es
gibt viel zu sagen man hat zwar
eigentlich lust wieder auf 6 aber ist
fahren die momentan das ist so eine
mythos damit wenn spontan 26 und beide
gleichzeitig luft und nach aus der also
wusste wie man will und in normaler
alltag das gar nicht so einfach ist und
wenn ich das mal vorschlag also wichtig
ist schon klasse unternehmen noch
irgendwie zu sexueller aktivität
benötigt werde also skalierung jetzt
statt sechs musik
das sehen wir jetzt mal frustriert
erfahren wie
es ist mit möglichst wenig wie also es
gibt viele wohl sagen es wisse wenn das
stattfindet oder das aber wichtig mit
plant berühmte für den staat findet man
seit ermöglichen vielseitige game of
thrones gelegt und stattdessen
vor dass reiter geräten richtig sechs
wichtig würden gelegentlich komme dass
allgemein sagen hat heinz garbe folgte
zurück macht sechs frei will er dort
sichtlich
bemüht das ist für die bezirks und ich
finde man muss es wirklich in ruhe aber
wenn es passt zu mir und ist nach dem
frack und lukas ist dafür nicht rufen
seine stimmige und sechs für mich ein
ort für kommunikation ist woran
zusätzliche ebene ihnen bringen
und bindet und nutze die reine sage aber
vorfreude sextape das sagen nur so viel
ich sage aber es ist schön so ja
aber
das
probiere interessante schau podcast
beziehungschaos extrem erfolgreich wird
aber wenn ich richtig informiert bin
ungefähr zu 80 prozent zu francos mache
ich das eigentlich wieso diese frage so
wahnsinnig beschäftigt wie viele
betriebe wohl fehlen der fall einmal
zugehört was ich sage es ist schwierig
mit den zahlen wir können sie nicht so
ganz genau jetzt aber das ist doch schon
so
therapie wegen der
krise gut gemacht das ist plötzlich viel
größeren anteil man darin dass man es
ganz schwer nachvollziehbar wenn jetzt
der bock gemacht dass nun aber sparen
spotify closed wird ist jünger wurde und
wo biete aber recht wahrscheinlich immer
nur filme irgendwie sozialisiert die
mannschaft und ich glaube
über
die geschichte der letzten
jahre das einzige ziel jetzt kümmere ich
glaube schon dass man armee man
gesprengt wird ich glaube im falle das
ist genetisch kleid sondern gestärkt
wird hier das untere bild das wird sich
das geflecht zwischen den einzelnen
menschen und dass das traurig dass der
roce früheren rasch laut also dass die
sagen hey wenn sie so weiter läuft könne
das richtige aber nicht gar nicht wo im
typischen fall aber das muss man viel
differenziertere bezirk zum beispiel ihr
seid lasst doch nur gesetz problem nicht
und musik gemein war das möglich gemacht
ja ja
das andere ich glaube es liegt daran
dass
zwei männer sind gemischte fonds die
rede
was macht man also
aber wenn sie zur bezirks kosmos von
zwei anderen wird gerade tut sich ein
anderer teil wird das glaube ich das
könnte sich als spannende dass man das
ziel womit zu mir zeitweilig zeit wie
bringe ich dir meine idee parat über die
präventive party dup seite sobald der
mann bot hier wird es eine klappe und
das ist sehr spannend inhalt zusammen
ein workshop gemacht die top ten sind
aktive und vorher nicht und wenn du
gefragt zb cix ist vor dem frankfurter
groß und man rennt einer wachsschicht
welche fallstricke kennt das schon
wichtig wenn derartiges ich konnte ihnen
und dann wieder fehler gemacht und ich
hoffe dass ihnen und am schluss bin ich
von der steuerschuld den kunst und das
haben ist spannend gefunden ist das
sogar dort wünscht solidarität zu haben
das produkt das achtbare
sichere und der durch sehr positiv
überrascht übrigens der mit dem podcast
das enorm wenn wohlwollen ist
gefährlich
ich würde gerne mal über die jüngere
rädern will man jetzt das thema wieder
so oft fällt es auch wie betrifft sind
die feste beziehung dar und die ganze
frage wie halten es die am laufen wenn
sie denn schon mal angefangen hat aber
wie vor zu überhaupt erst mal an und wie
ist ihre diagnose von einem generation
beziehungsunfähig wo man sich so im raum
statt also wir nehmen das wahr wie hätte
ich lieber für andere ist es schwieriger
geworden ist das befreiend wie sie jetzt
gerade ja so gut die fragen ich finde es
sehr wichtig stelle und ich habe ein
problem mit zu labels wie er beziehung
die ganze generation heißt
beziehungsproblem was ich schon
wahrnehmen ist dass du das riesigen
angebot an möglichkeit einfach verwirrt
ich mein größter ist was nehme jetzt vor
dem buffet also das sind ja wirklich die
viele viele titel sind auswählen und vor
allem das thema ist als jurke gewisse
grenzen gewisse verlässlichkeit durch
ihr die beziehung zum funktionieren und
das teilweise auch erlaubt wird die
spielerinnen immer also was ich schon
waren immer große verunsicherung teil
wie es vor was natürlich was will ich
und und wir wie es entspannend wie es
hieß das ist ganz oft dargestellt also
was soll so
wichtig für mich
objektiv war das aber wohl nicht also
ich merke es bezirks thema ist teil
dieser sehr verkopft wieder junge
generation ich hoffe es klappt dann
jemand wie ich finde es immer schwierig
vom mimik standpunkt also gerade auf
andere generation aber nicht mit
denn so sagen wir es mal wieder sieht
aber was ich merke ich es ist wahnsinnig
viel sich gedanken machen darum und das
ist gut aber das gerade etwas zu viel es
geht nicht nur das ziel retten es gibt
aber ist viel danke ich denke ich denke
zu viel also das sind wichtige themen
und ich tatsächlich so plant in exile
jetzt fertig podcast 3cx kosmos mit lost
bis sechs cent will ich wette dass du
jetzt mal
gewartet was müsse noch besprochen und
das findet einige sehr sehr schwierig
wir denken dass eine bewegungsform sie
war wenn ich immer mehr konsumiert und
mich immer mehr mit diesen befassen muss
ich doch zum schluss froh und dafür
komplett also im rat und ich bin ich
mein so die vorstellung die ich
natürlich wahnsinnig kann man sagen
archiv und und viel zu romantisch aber
die vorstellung es runter beruhen und
hals bereits wieder blitzt es trifft
mich ich verliere mich dass ich sowieso
trilux ich habe bis größer wenn ich es
wieder fahrt und gegenüber grund medien
und seelsorge der tatsächlich wird die
sims herzklopfen wo es um trieb sonst
hochzeit lieber entlastet wurden über
voller bücher was er jetzt mehr passt
jetzt den pudding zu irritieren und das
ist schwierig und wenn es hilfe so
riesige schwer zahnlos komplizierte aber
die haben denn zudem vertrauen zurück
finden also wir mal angefangen hofft sie
dass keine mehr seit er ist ein sehr
beliebtes dingen die andere sache mal
angefangen hofft sie dennoch wieder
sagen ich warte darauf dass mich
überkommt mich nicht einfach er will
frauen wider erwarten war dass mich
leute vielleicht über und ich glaube
fest er war ja wirklich
langsamer machen wie man zu wenig zeit
aber eigentlich wirklich zeigen haye
versucht man einfach aber gar nicht
sagen ich will jetzt rufen danken dass
ich wieder mit dem dank des dankes stock
bin ich immer schwierig sondern wirklich
mal spazieren sitze worte und vor allem
nicht nur von denen dritter konsumieren
und weiter zum beispiel social media
aber ich denke ich muss euch gesagt ich
bin jetzt eine plattform für die im
rausch wer ich bin jetzt hinter kenne
aber android also die dating-plattform
nicht nur kennt das ja das haben wir
damals gar nicht mal mit dem
freundeskreis
und das ist nix über das glück hat okay
das gap ist und ich habe darum nicht mit
rädern aus erster hand aber
dass die liegt die nachbereitung
speziell zwei tore
das ist etwas wo ja auch nicht ganz so
einfach ist denn sagen hey blieben
premiere seine gäste so ein blitzschlag
erlaubt und 2b jura und schob das leder
stärker leuchten am himmel das macht es
natürlich sehr schwierig jetzt finden
was bedeutet das eigentlich und ich
finds tempo vor der generation war mir
jetzt geredet hat da wir uns im harz ist
das betrifft übrigens ganz viel zum
thema nur sprachlos war aber das fällt
mir so oft wenn wir doch ist kino garten
unter dach und fach sein ohne handy das
geht es einfach
lässig mit großem kino er schlage vor
empfehlen und nicht möglichkeit sms chat
kann oder lukrative passiert war noch
schwimmt er hat mir viele ignorieren
und jetzt stelle ich mir sauber fest ich
komme aus club wahrscheinlich etwas los
muss irgendwo an irgendwas mit trend
unschuld - und ich werde mich oft wo
bliebe die intensive gefühl wonach es
noch ein hier kann machte nochmal beim
svww in schwarz ich glaube es so großer
kulturpessimismus also
dass die jungen hinter für ein anderer
umgang mit der sache das hat auch noch
wirke wenn ich noch es weiter innerlich
wirkt das noch untersagen also ich würde
es das nicht sagen dass das irgendwie
flachen werden das heißt die junge
richtung jung ich würde auch die
drehscheibe zwischen
22 53 ist also
wirklich eher wie du also ich glaube
ich sehe seine pessimistisch ich glaube
das ist live-acts wisse dass werden
jetzt schnell ein import übernahm
glättet dass sich davon nicht gleich die
ehefrau vorarbeiter das ist wie wenn du
steiß wasser rasch und gezielt fahrer
untertourig oder nächste steigt und du
bist beschäftigt mit der nächsten wahl
mit der über die am höchsten ist und
wenn paar träume das ist gar nicht mal
zurück zumindest profession aber ich
mache das aber ich achte eine omega
zieht ist genau das was im zieht und es
mir schütze war nicht mehr lange mit ins
handy ist wahrlich ein input und was ich
bin wichtig finde überhaupt die
pessimistischen gegenteil ich finde sich
ein live-act hey leute müssen so groß
wie mozzarella was ich
sage bewusst mit unklar wie viel man
schon einen trigger wenn und alina und
das finde ich ihre kultur einfach einen
frieden strategie zum können ein teil
ist hat er viel gelernt und so ist es ja
ein schlimmer schock sie kultur ist
umgeschlagen techniken eher schlecht
oder gut sondern immer der geruch wird
technikum es sind halt immer noch rar
der gebrauch von ihrer digitaler
technologie richtig zu lernen aber
vielleicht zurück zu den bezügen und der
unter psychologie aber ziemlich klasse
beschäftigen derzeit die der woche
zeitig die zeit vorwoche titelthema kann
das nur alles kaputt psychologisiert
sind nützliche überspitzt sein
die darin aber charme für äußere seeland
in der therapie und sie stehen
differenzierte betrachtung zeigt
natürlich das positiv aber darum
emanzipation und enzian und redet über
die gefühle über die befindlichkeit vor
allem menschen wirklich psychisch krank
sind wir zum glück wird oftmals hilft
wenn es glück hand genug therapieplatz
geht aber aber es gibt es du und reisen
um sich sagt und mehr und mehr für 160
logi zur selbstoptimierung muss immer
nur darum gott zur leistungsfähiger zu
machen sich sie haben noch ganz voll
genommen irgendjemand starken und
individueller zum leuchten zu bringen
das zehnte stück wie kritisch an warum
hintergrund dass der ganze trend
also zwei coaching zum beispiel die
große welle um die psychologie
zeitschrift im silicon valley entstand
aus dem california la massa und die
meisten trends im bereich zurück ich
habe patrick und ich finde es wirklich
wichtiges thema aktualisieren das sagt
edwin das arbeitsfeld obwohl ich
natürlich sehr begrüßen nicht nur wie
das mit durch stand ist sondern also
mini nachhaltig also ich finde es
einfach wertvoll weil man viel
verständlicher funktioniert das hin zum
fahrrad verstarb ich könnte dich
vielleicht dank für das mini gegenüber
funktioniert will ich glaube wir haben
die besseren kontakt aber auch zum
ausschließlich bietet und dabei
vielleicht paradox ich bin richtig
allergisch gegen sie selbst optimierungs
geschichte war meine eigene aber
wirtschaftsvertreter mit zum besser war
der am schlimmsten aber ich muss so
entgegnet sie und zwischen der saga zum
schluss und etwas ratlos aufgabe gemacht
also zum nächsten machen und angebliche
zoff gab mit dem darf nur beobachten und
das ist ganz schweizer muss
hauptsächlich seite nur beobachten und
notizen machen und am heck und das und
das wird so kreativ das holte aber für
unruh irgend welche assoziationen so und
ich finde das sofa vor etwas nicht
direkt ob denn da wo das ding kreist
sondern ist manisch älter jährige esra
mit das ist sparen und netzwerk theorie
manchmal ist einfach so wie eine gang
weiß doch ging hongkongs entwicklung
können user und plötzlich gibt es
frisches behindert und sieben zurück und
sagt hey jetzt
und wenn ich zeit für diese und los geht
s um 1000 aus und leistet dieses und
diese sind dieses hat schon gut wie
nicht verändert haben und das ist so
und mit dem tschuldigung ich aber dass
in frage stellen
das thema klingt wenn wir dir zu lasten
der podcast gott so oft um die chemie
geschichte also dass wir alle so
extremen so bin ich
standardtechnologien und das heißt da
das wenn ich jetzt so spritzig hat mit
dem ihf und ehf reagiert dafür biss den
seite steht die irische magdeburg sie
und immer mit dem thema vertraut was ich
mache ist nico aggressiv und die
wahrscheinlich wieder der klinik uhr
aktiviert und denker nicht dann geduldig
sie so und sagenfiguren und so weiter
du brauchst das ist sogar stützt
es ist so und das also dass das glas ist
natürlich bezeugt das laub ich glaube
mit cent meine schnitt dass es exakt 100
moment lösungen eigentlich findet foren
anders verhalten habe wo ich gerade bin
ruhig verhalte die psychologie qualität
was er sagen wird qualität ich sehe
nicht ihre dank musste ich sie nicht
gekühlt
aber ich versuche sie zu interpretieren
aber zum start up läuft müsste man
fragen und das ist das thema aber das
war mir die frage was ich zu stark und
ich sage dazu schmunzelt hauptziel war
nicht dass du dich
sondern durch natürlich genau das macht
mir jetzt aber geht es schon 15 mal
besprochen jetzt schon wieder das ziel
war dass man die art der mustert uns
nicht mal merken und das ist versprochen
habe dass man die engagierten aber das
bedingt dass sind psychologisierung geht
dass wir alle sensibler werden ich sage
besser beobachten die andere und müsse
da geht es natürlich solche die
psychologische psychotherapeut blick auf
der anderen hin müssen das sind mussten
die sind die kindheit wettstreit wurde
also das braucht aber so mit der
beziehung gut funktionieren alles andere
war einfach kalt und darum geht das dann
erfordert genau und es geht aber die
grenze was zählt wie viele also die
psychologisierung begriff sich extrem
will die etwas die offenheit sitzung ist
für die themen das ist groß sein und
gleichzeitig aber wirklich zeigen mini
aufgabe stehen also wenn lithium ihre
mit aber den finger drauf selber wenig
merkt jetzt reizt aber notare wo sie
peter wack damit verziert cannstatt
bürger zu sichern und das aber zuviel
und zuwenig die waagschale das ist aber
wieso wo man hat das leere dass die
einer stunde und arbeitswillig das ist
neu vielleicht spiele ich
interessiert dennoch wie können wir denn
eigentlich damit um dass es zur sache
geht weil man andere wirklich aufregend
so ist das einfach oder und da allein
philosoph wo viel über sie geschrieben
hat und zwar vor allem
interessanterweise über fragen wie gott
liege wieder die partei bislang haben
erst in völliger irrglaube für tasse
gefahr einander der jetzt erzieher
sondern es hat natürlich wären ja auch
sich hin zwar ist der partner nicht als
kind aber die schauer bewundert und sich
doch gut an andere zu arzt halten sagt
es verbessere und aufhöre nehmen viel am
setup mit erzieherin das ist eigentlich
total das wo paartherapeuten immer sagen
niederzier und dazu würde wieder sagen
es gab wiederum es marx es geht darum
dass man für diese erwartungen bringe es
gibt eine sache man darf sagen das ist
für mich im conditio sine qua non das
blut zum weitermachen
und es geht aber etwas wie bison ist
eine sonne mitten im ort was immer ich
bin jetzt erfahren ist
wenn ich zu viel und ich würde sagen es
produkte die mission risiken und der
ganze aber es gibt
einfach nur froh wenn ihr alle seid es
gibt aber grenzen uns zu uns maßen zur
halbzeit teilen was ist denn los
wenn wir nicht offen ist die perspektive
für andere personen wenn wir zu stellen
dass jede politik
politik und chemotherapie war im sommer
wird
das hat schon neue pop kaufverhalten es
gab zwar sportlich hin verbessern müssen
um sorge wir sind froh wenn du willst
dich wird strände 40 tagen also wäre das
schädigend für den
film tatsächlich auch schon mal leid ist
oder nicht macht
das geschäftsmodell ist will es gut zum
gott
ich weiß es nicht ich glaube dir
wirklich verstanden hat was ich immer
verzeihen würde zeige die wird sich das
gut über leitern und dankbar das ist
beste musik gemacht aber durch muslime
das wird heiss sporttherapeuten und sie
schafft es nicht einmal bis nicht es
gibt es bliebe aber mit dem wappen
mit verminderten mit familie
paartherapie
die frage dich gibts eigentlich
klientinnen und klienten wo die richtig
auf den weg
ja das gibt das gibt es das dorf st der
punkt ist genau die zeit ist das ist
dann realisiert und arnim und versuche
trotzdem offen blieb aber das ist
auch dass
sie meister und große anteil fast alle
ich finde senat wird eigentlich aber das
ist normal wenn manche kennen wie sie
wirklich sind finde ich gezwungen man
schon nicht
das ist mir wichtig das richtige
standort wirklich die authentizität 832
meiner mannschaft ein kompliment ist
doch meines lebens werte schafft wäre
mir nie verstanden ist was die person
seit das nämlich dass es wunderschön
schluss wo danke dir dass du zur
äußerung bis zur bleichung bossert ja
und dann natürlich für euch wissen kann
dir in eine therapie betont oder könnt
ihr euch hauptsächlich auf den weg als
gern gekommen darunter und wenn der
medien vergleichen passat dann abonniere
doch glocken oder kanal westi